without going into details I was in the
Hermes store okay now what were you
doing in there I just was in there for a
good question again it's too boring a
story however sir you can help me with
this
they have bags there that are oh yeah
now they look like [ __ ] regular
batteries no I mean by regular as it
gets
I know $10,000 Oh $8,000 quality bro can
you explain that to me because you are
you I know you appreciate this I I had
to bring the guy over you have to
explain to me how this is the gun oh I
see okay so so so that's $34,000 right
there well the same though like so that
Hermes bag how rare it is same as the
cabinet a gt3 or something you know like
there's not a ton of them out and the
quality that goes into it that's $15,000
I know dude that's 27,000 oh there's a
hundred look at that dude with it
there's a $30,000 purses man you can
spend some like scrubs and crocodile and
[ __ ] just leave that $131,000
what yeah let me see that
are you into bags purses yeah my mom
really is she tries to get me into it
but I'm not very are you more of a
tomboy yeah I definitely like you'd
rather get a [ __ ] uh some wraps to do
deadlift than a gym bag oh yeah and then
like that Hermes bag that's a hundred
and five thousand dollars but like
you're not into like Gucci and stuff
well I feel like I don't have anywhere
to wear it to like all I really do is
like work or go to school before I'm at
home like I'm not gonna walk around in a
saline bag while I'm like at the gym or
something 331 thousand dollars now bags
are [ __ ] crazy man but IIIi think
it's the ultimate example of how insane
human beings can be that's $34,000
Brendan so now if you had the money
would you buy a bag like that I mean if
my girl wanna yeah that's what she was
into if I was like Scrooge McDuck rich I
don't give a [ __ ] at all really no why
would I give a [ __ ]
these are the men's bags though would
you buy it for yourself that's a men's
bag yeah no I don't need I wouldn't use
it I have no problem like the faint like
the expensive fan
Paxson [ __ ] they're cool to make sense
but it's just not my thing yeah how much
for those fanny packs even if they're
like a hundred bucks that's too much I
think for a fanny pack
like probably like three to four grand
for a fanny pack
if reads like the Gucci Leather one yeah
oh yeah those really in right now
they're super in right now well I guess
it's like anything else it's a status
symbol right I mean yeah that's bottom
line I mean wow that's 1200 every young
dude at my other job rocks that exact
Gucci bag that white one
yeah and they wear like crossbody yeah
that's that's weird delete how's a bit
on it's hilarious that's interesting
they're in right now dude Wow yeah well
listen um I think they make sense though
carry all your [ __ ] probably how do you
need a Gucci one for 1,200 probably not
but I hate when stuffs in my pocket that
would make way more sense yeah I have a
little more soupy ol pouch yeah like a
little kangaroo yeah man drew I call
that a man Roo he's a man let your thing
dude I'm just saying if you wanna but a
habit wait like for you wine right like
you'd spend a shitload online I
understand I'm never a nice when I went
as a $4 bottle I go III drool yeah yeah
yeah and a thousand thousand for others
not [ __ ] for one like for another all
right whatever I mean you can spend
$5,000 on wisely yeah and to me I taste
some acai taste like that [ __ ] yep
barefoot and it probably does maybe
let's simply well again you're looking
at like the age like an essay a 1982
château Lafite you know it's like the
amount of care that went into the wine
all that goes in the hand stitching
there's some real you know Hermes is
real cause it marked up like a
[ __ ] use the high piece behind
it of course the demand everything but
then again just try to get just try to
start a company where you confess that
kind of price they can do it right
something right I'm always respectful
and honest that is like someone who's
like but I can feel is what you do you
go like hey honestly let me tell you so
you're gonna preface this by saying
honestly which means the rest of what
you're saying is [ __ ]
that's you bryan callen chin
yeah here's here's you you're doing the
Goldbergs it's going great and they're
like oh we're thinking of spinning this
character often they're thinking about
doing school and blah blah blah and
here's how you add to that and you fall
into it you're [ __ ] that's your
entire [ __ ] career don't know I wrote
I wrote down my dream board and I can
show it to you I bet your dream board is
a cork board in your bathroom and it's
got three pictures on it yeah there's a
[ __ ] a canoe and a lake there's a
[ __ ] pair of suede shoes and a little
red chair okay why that's what you got
well why would all that be on my train
board that's all you got going on up
here
I got a canoe in a lake what yes I feel
like I'm a canoe on a giant lake no
you're like I want to go out in nature
whatever in nature and then you wanna
then you want in the you like nature so
nature is one of my goals yeah [ __ ]
going out in nature which is someone
usually you're gonna be hiking out there
amongst the the roots and rocks and you
lose and fall in the water and you wish
you had a canoe you better shut up or
I'm gonna [ __ ] punch you and I'd love
to see it don't I didn't flinch okay
well you know what that means I've got
some ideas listen man don't I do and I
come home told you not do you lie to
defend yourself
[Music]
I came out of me man you scared me you
just got as a serious coward yeah okay
you just got at it as a fart fart and
coward right that's not good for my rap
no it's why would you do that because I
didn't know that you'd be a fart fart
and coward if I came at you yeah but I
want look at me adjusting in this
[ __ ] chair man there did you have
your chairs over there you need to
defend yourself
oh yeah well I want you to think up a
big tough guy and you exposed me it was
a photo you fetal DUP and started
farting man fetal fartin keep your eyes
open and look at me encounter maybe I
could do some fight training us alright
so let's try it again but keep your eyes
open now just please don't do it got a
[ __ ] stupid
come on I'm not gonna hit you just keep
your head up and keep your eye you're
already [ __ ] I'm knocking flinching
and coward lessness when people are
cowards some really brings out the mean
in me dude had something in my eye
you're a bully [ __ ] judo don't you
can have your eyes open to it [ __ ]
hands up oh did that kill matter me did
that come out of me that's disgusting
you're a [ __ ] Oh smells like [ __ ]
human [ __ ] I was in the oxygen out
before it works I can't even come out
God did you place a little [ __ ] girl
in yo you're a fart farting coward
you're a human skunk yeah dude you're a
human sign know I'm a big fart and polar
bear that was impressive goddamn it
stinks in here
so schooled out did school did good
school doubt it's raining out today you
know and I just want to grab blank and
snuggle up you see how it happens you on
the rain I read a book by the window
with a cat in your lap hurled up the
rain
I think apparently according to a lot of
social experiments causes people to be a
little bit naughty err have sex well
there's no also also also they'll tend
to steal a little more like so if
there's an honor system where you got a
bagel people take a bagel and in the
office you're supposed to put a dollar
it down for the bagel but the rain makes
them feel will typically not put the
dollar down to sling rain or they'll
take someone else's food when it's
raining and the reason they think is
maybe because it's a little bit you know
it's like cloudy so nobody close see
Hubbard yeah you'd be an idiot to think
you're still in the rain uh getting
caught that's that's I do all my heist
in the rain do
do it in the night in the night rain
demands cold so we need more body heat I
mean this asides dude that will have to
cause arousal therefore sex I mean snow
not [ __ ] breaking the internet here
yeah I mean I know people who have that
that my friend's girlfriend had that
seasonal disorder depression in the
seasonal when it would rain she simply
couldn't get out of bed oh oh oh the
seasonal we call it crazy yeah a train
she couldn't get out of bed yeah when it
was cloudy when it was wasn't sunny it
was oh is that a real thing just a real
thing
chin DF seasonal [ __ ] no I don't think I
do that when he's on kratom not where
knees on great oh I mean I guess my
serotonin is not as high when it's
cloudy out when it's sunny it's [ __ ]
out you're driving to work like yeah
yeah yes that but there there is a level
of serotonin in our brains that's
natural some people have it at for
seasonal depression I'm sure it's a real
thing he's not affective disorder when
it gets hot out I wanna [ __ ] is there
something for that well you know what
dude when it's when I'm in like Miami in
Toronto the weather when it's like when
it's I swear to God when it's steamy and
it's like icky I wanna I want to get
down on me oh no ticky I was born in
that climate I was born in the
Philippines which is very tropical and
they say that you tend to guy kind of
like where you were born you will tend
to that that environment is I've heard
that it might be bro science of course
but signs of seasonal depression include
feeling depressed most of the day nearly
every day okay well it's just depression
losing interest in activities you once
enjoyed having low energy having
problems with shape Chuck experiencing
changes in your appetite feeling
sluggish or agitated shack having
difficulty concentrating in check
feeling hopeless worthless or guilty
well no check having frequent thoughts
of death or suicide no no check fallen
winter who the [ __ ] gets the proper
spacing I'm right changes in summer who
gets the present summer
nobody I don't know some people can't
deal with the the heat yeah it's like
the
sky this guy who was our guide this uh
you know he was like not cold at all we
were we were wearing four layers in the
morning and freezing and he's in a
t-shirt and I go how could how are you
not cold I finally had to say it he goes
because it's not cold I was like honey
but he can't deal with the heat the heat
kills him
can't move does he get depressed off it
though no it's so cloudy I'm just like
yeah maybe I'm a little more lazy like
alright know when it's a little more
comfort food you know I'm saying but
when it's really hot the two things if
you're in Boston in the wintertime
you're not going outside when you drive
down the street the streets are [ __ ]
empty it's too cold
it's it's you people just in a lot of
time when I was and when I was but
Stevie and I were and I think in Boston
in January something whatever was it was
really cold and I and I was like um he
goes I go what do you wanna do tomorrow
I goes what no nothing not going
anywhere
I know what do you mean he goes well
it's too it's too cold I was like well
well can you rap bro I gotta be in
Edmonton this week and Rogan sent me a
screenshot cuz where you going
everything a screenshot of the weather
zero and one degree your eyes are kind
of dead this morning well ah that's
annoying oh my god can you not bring a
an office size cooler jug of water get a
bigger chair these chairs constrain my
hips well do a way that I'm not
comfortable with well I can't I can't
bring in a bigger chair for just because
getting bigger chairs for boethius well
Brendan's a big guy he's got a big
athletic high bubble but he does how he
that's how he [ __ ] trains that's how
he beat the [ __ ] out of people
yeah he's got her years and years I got
a high athletic bubble but yeah but it's
little and cute little cute bubble but
Brian Callens ass that's the but the
fits in a red chair
and I read hey man how long does open go
give him no sass what how long's the
show been going this mom well it's been
going on for about five maybe 10 min
apini year bro thanks but really really
appreciative thanks for having so much
I'd like to say hello to all your
listeners of course yeah
they're there people that I adore
they're people that I feel close to and
more importantly they feel close to me
yeah and that's my responsibility that's
why I showed up today okay when you
asked it has nothing to do with our
[ __ ] French okay okay
they're ours and years of that all right
because I respect these people yeah I
never know what I'm dealing with with
you because you tend to float from mood
to mood so I yeah I don't know what I'm
coming I don't know what when you come
in I don't know what kind of cloud I'm
gonna have to deal with you know what
I'm saying brought unpredictable you
could call it exciting but sure there's
a large logic worm swimming around in my
brain yeah there's a logic worms and you
don't know where it's gonna stop now
what's that logic do you ever just want
to kill a bunch of people yeah sometimes
I just want to I just want to slide into
the I just want to go into the forest
yeah and I just want to get I just want
to get people and I want to put them in
cloaks oh boy and I want to and I want
to preach to them and I want to promise
them things so you want to create a
druid Society I want to create a druid
Society and a cauldron we would have a
cauldron what would be in said cauldron
said cauldron they would be well first
we'd start with bark bark yeah we're
going to take the river water the water
from the creek got to be careful with
bark cuz some bark can be very poisonous
Canadore who that is Jon to the point
got it I got it while everybody's
drinking from the cauldron yeah I'm
drinking from the black cistern okay and
that's in the black cistern ah clam
chowder usually okay I thought maybe I
thought maybe some kind of a like bat
blood or something like that just got a
clamp ah Jesus why wouldn't I give that
to you as it's a gift it's a gift